reaction to all of this florida senator
marco rubio
let let's start with the guy we knew
four years ago and 10 years ago or the
guy
that debated paul ryan um
i see a dramatic
significant decline he looks weak frail
and i
obviously he's struggling cognitively
senator am i
if you disagree you tell me i'm wrong
well i'll tell you what else it reveals
it reveals the hypocrisy and i remember
rick perry was torn apart and mocked by
the press because they couldn't remember
something in a in a debate
you know i myself was torn apart in a
debate because i repeated the same thing
three times
i mean it's just a complete double
standard it's just one more example of
it you know and and it's unfortunate but
i also think we have to understand
something i mean
if you're a foreign leader and you're
watching this stuff they're going to
make their own assessments about what
they think they can get away with
are they dealing with a weak leader are
they dealing with someone that really
doesn't have control of the situation
is he just an instrument and a puppet
for the radical you know out of control
lunacy of the far left in his party and
they're just using his presidency to
sort of achieve these things that
they've been trying to do forever and
and i think there's a lot of let me
remember the president of mexico
i believe it was today there's no way
they leave that meeting feeling like
they're dealing with a strong leader
you see what's going on in the borders
imagine for a second now
it was it wasn't donald trump that built
the cages for the kids that was
biden and obama uh can you imagine if
donald trump actually
put kids in cargo storage containers on
ships with bars in the window won't let
the media take a look at what's inside
but we're told that there's pictures of
beautiful butterflies on the wall
and we should be okay with kids in cargo
containers uh it doesn't sound that
accommodating and uh
inviting to me senator yeah but the real
tragedy begins well before they get into
those centers is the fact that
how are these people getting here
they're getting here because trafficking
networks
are taking advantage of poor desperate
people and they're telling them
there's a new president this new
president will let you come into the
united states and stay there if you show
up with a child
so now you've created an incentive for
children to be sent on that journey
we have no idea how many of these
children are are killed on that journey
left behind die from illness on that
journey
are sexually abused on that journey by
these evil trafficking networks
all incentivized by a policy and what we
wind up with
is complete utter ridiculousness today
it is
easier in many ways to show up at the
border of the united states and gain
entry into this country
than it is for an american to come to
the capitol and see their member of
congress
it's we've got house members have to go
through a through a metal detector to go
vote
but if you show up at the border your
ability to stay in the country
with a child your ability to stay in the
country is dramatically increased we're
going to have hundreds of thousands of
people because the word is out in
central america
that if you show up at the border with a
child they're going to let you in
they're going to let you stay
and you're just going to see more and
more people coming it's a terrible
tragedy
and by the way it's not good for this
country either there's a lot of double
standards in this world
and a lot of phony media reporting we
saw that with russia right we did have a
dirty russian dossier hillary paid for
it was used to spy on a president and a
presidential candidate those are all
facts at this point
uh that happened we had a ukraine
impeachment
but we have joe biden leveraging a
billion taxpayer dollars
to get a prosecutor in ukraine fired
because we find out his zero experienced
50 year old son
is making millions just like millions
from oligarchs in
russia and the bank of china the 1.5
billion
deal there a lot of double standards you
were there for the kavanagh hearing
senator
and we saw how that man was treated and
we saw him
his family frankly brutalized and we saw
uh many people's stories fall apart
right before our eyes
and now you got the situation where the
i believers are silent
on the issue of serious allegations
against new york governor andrew cuomo
and by the way two women during the
campaign that came out against joe biden
uh now he's saying he wants an
investigation into cuomo
should these standards be applied
equally yeah i actually think they
should be applied at a higher standard
the allegations against kavanaugh were
allegations
that happened you know 20 30 years ago
when he was a high school student and a
college student and look
not not to say that allegations of
somebody actually did that which was
never proven that it wouldn't be bad
these allegations are about a man in a
position of power okay
a position of power a governor of the
third largest state in the country
who has a position of power over the
people that now accuse him
it's a that happened you know two three
four five seven years ago
so the standard should actually be
higher and uh you know al franken
resigned from the united states senate
under pressure from his colleagues
because of some insensitive things he
said to people on uso tours
these are allegations of someone using
their power as a governor over a staff
member
over someone who inferior to them in the
power structure
so you think about that for a moment and
how long it took for some of these
networks to even
talk about it the only reason they're
talking about it now is because they're
three accusers
yeah all right uh senator uh interesting
times we'll see
if the i believer caucus starts to speak
out
they're a little late already senator
good to see you thank you for being with
us